nein nein nein nein nein
hallo ich meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen zurück in der today show
folge 69 zusammen mit denen hallo hallo
konny reimann taylor diana von alex am
ein mops bonner gefunden auf facebook
geschrieben
lena und können ihr ein mann was haltet
ihr von simcity 5 oder was erwartet ihre
form
ich hab kein simcity teil vorher
gespielt aber ich denke für city 4 ist
es doch oder
5 das heißt eigentlich nur simcity aber
der die vorgänge als eigentlich positiv
ihrer nachhaltig sei dies aber es war
kein richtiger das war total cup und
schlecht und alles das heißt jetzt neue
simcity aber sozusagen city 5 ja ich
werde es mir auf jeden fall holen weil
ich diese video star auf youtube gesehen
habe und das sieht echt sehr interessant
aus youtube youtube weil es im city auf
dem kanal gut startet die bücher
gefunden und so was von den gaming boxen
wie 40 mit video gesehen als ich mein
vater schon als vorteil dass vor jahren
angekündigt schon jetzt die zeit dank
angekündigt war jedenfalls sonntagsspiel
und jetzt
und das ist kacke wird aber welche
ganzen wie das ich bisher gesehen habe
vielleicht ziemlich fett aus als ich
sagen alle ziemlich geil was auch aus
der beta dann als von so als ganz
normales gameplay fand ich ziemlich
schön alles auch beim pc komm grad an
wenn wir ihn zum update andrehen will
ich jetzt nicht
keine ahnung also diese ganzen videos
die ich gesehen hab ich dachte immer
simcity damals ganz ganz damals hat ein
kumpel von mir sin city 2 es ist sehr
sehr lange her und das also wenn man
diese ja da kann man nicht das aufs
schiff 2000 und 2003 reingesprungen eine
ahnung ich hab keine ahnung jedenfalls
meinte er sehr voll geil ich konnte ihm
wird spielen das so und ich fand es
nicht so geil weil ich habe das ganz
anders vorgestellt aber zum city vier
oder fünf oder keine ahnung was das
jetzt muss ich schon sagen diese videos
dass man da die unter die bauwerke die
man dort baut mit wasser versorgen muss
mental feuerwehr bauen muss damit da
nicht so viele diebstähle passieren in
der stadt und so was was man sich halt
nicht alles kann man muss das finde ich
sehr gut vor allem das ist ein
strategiespiel ist was so toll
aufgemacht ist es gibt es rechts elton
und so einfach aufgebaut und deswegen
vielleicht das eingangs kurz sich jetzt
mit kaufen
let's play dazu machen weiß ich nicht
weil keine ahnung von dem spiel ich
meine ich würds mir selber nicht von
anderen leuten angucken deswegen weil
sich nicht du machst dir 1 ich werde
weitermachen ja aber ich weiß noch gar
nicht wie ich das machen weil ich werde
das so suchten und dann wenn ich das
spiel damit so viele freundlich so lange
folgen weiß nicht genau oder ich mache
playbackshow welt kann man recht machen
und eine normale sockelbeträge hat das
erste spiel seit langem was ich mal
wieder außerhalb vom netz play off
balance macht so fangen ich habe es nie
gespielt und simcity 5 als das neue city
hat nicht mehr komplett die komplexität
von simcity 4
aber ist noch ziemlich weil das ist echt
richtig krass kompliziert alles gewesene
filmcity 4
und was es da alles gab es richtig
kompliziert und nicht
einsteigerfreundlich aber die ganzen
daten sind halt so richtig gut aufgebaut
in der im 19
city hat man ja wie das gesehen hat mir
wieder aufgebaut richtig genial da
können sich echt stadt die die spiele
eine scheibe von abschneiden
moderne strategiespiele da kann man
sehen wie man komplexe materien trotzdem
noch verständlich für einsteiger
aufbereitet und spiele dem ist für leute
die komplexe sachen wollen aber auch für
einsteiger halt gleichermaßen bieten
kann und einfach ein jahr als ich werde
so was von spiel spiel spielen und das
wird glaube ich richtig gut die städte
sind bissig klein im vorletzten city 4
aber ich glaub ich werd damit klar
kommen und man kann endlich kurven bauen
ist auch cool kurs und sensitive links
ging das nicht wollen so vorgefertigt
kochen oder ich weiß nicht mehr genau
oder gar keine kurven halt nur so schräg
oder oder gerade ja ich wieder vom 22
ich denke wenn ich würde mir wird das
oft in die kommentare geschrieben als
ich einmal was im city geredet habe vor
ein paar wochen in
lost video kommentare geschrieben dass
der von display machen sind aber ich
denke wenn ich eins machen würde würde
ich auf keinen fall das als aufnehmen
wenn ich das spielen würde und dann die
ganze zeit zu quatschen wir finden nicht
cool sondern ich würde dann einfach das
sind ein paar platz machen dass ich mal
so ab und ziehen ihren meine hallo
ja ich hatte mich hast du mich ich höre
dich ja du hast mir kurz weg jetzt ist
er wieder da ist bei mir alles
funktioniert im microsoft der merkwürdig
sehr merkwürdig was ich war gerade das
ist gefunden hat dabei dass ich
wahrscheinlich ein letztlich so
gestalten werde dass ich nicht länger
sondern mal ab und zu ein paar parts
aufnehmen werde und dass ich da dann
zwar größere veränderungen als zwischen
den part sind aber dass ich das dann
halt nur so manchmal auf nehmt euch mal
dass ein bisschen zeige wie sich das
alles verändert hat und blabla aber ich
will nicht so ein komplettes display
machen weil kein leben bleibe ich nicht
voll dann das wird dann genauso wieder
ultimate team ablaufen bei mir mit fifa
ich werde dann spielen und nicht immer
aufnehmen sondern einfach so weiter wie
gehabt für ein smaragd krieg zu vier
brote viel spaß hast du kannst du noch
weiter klicken da nämlich immer und x3
glos druck für einen er natürlich du
kannst auf einem dorfbewohner
weiterklicken nehme nur wenn du einmal
mit ihm gehandelt hat oder so
mann ich möchte dass ihr die kugel kids
kino am 10
da wieder in englisch elf bücher für
einen award und dem bücher h ich glaube
jetzt die bücher und kippten zurück mein
gott
gute sache war ein echter ice cold calls
haben wir ein thema gab die wesentlichen
aus dem city erst einmal ins gewissen
ja ich weiß bin vorstellte thema wenn er
so schön dringen
denn was willst du hier mit vergessen so
was als elf bücher ab 21 was auf 1
wollte man mir fehlt ein fucking buch
komm schon den rabatt junge dieser
rabatt ein schales buchmann skm sein
was braucht man für ein buch ein leder
und 343 papier braucht
ein penalty gehandelte bloggers sogar
witze vielleicht neues geschäft machen
ist lässt er mitnehmen aus der tür aus
bicek brad pitt bis jetzt zerstört sein
haus weise mal wieder sein setup
reagieren allerdings bekommt ihr für 3m
world eine schere cool was überhaupt los
morgen bekommen
drei obsidian ein schwert und drei eisen
bronze kiste bahrenfelder ich freue mich
jetzt schon auf die wirklich auf den
rückblick auf ihre geräte herstellen was
macht ihr hier
bücher das gleiche würde wäre ich machen
laufen erklärt die rettungssanitäter
zehn fische für eines aus stoff sie dann
tag einfach ist ja schon hat ihn ganz
vorn liegt danach einfach mal die trave
ärgern ganze zeit nur rumlaufen als
projekt vor sondern das haus rein hier
ist keiner an wohnt überhaupt jemand ja
jemand der zwölf fisch kaufen will
abschneide halsabschneider sind es
riesigen dschungel gefunden er will ich
handel mit mir die auch nicht also jetzt
mal an gib mir doch mal ein dschungel
tempel oder wenn ich irgendwie das schon
deine wüste das noch geiler als ob es
stimmt oder so bitte ich habe diese den
als komplette spiel hast uns das essen
im laufwerk nach hause mit 12 level
immerhin schon immerhin sah mich so ein
bisschen level wie schlecht mit aufwärts
nach hause in dem ich ihn dahin laufe
und was es hierhin auf verkehr total
fall auch hier bin ich wenigstens weit
weg gekommen
in ganz neue gefilde oder im dorf
gefunden also macht die ganze zeit und
dann gar nicht
ja ich vor allem finde ich keine schuld
jemand nicht mein so spielt es
eigentlich auch nicht
aber anscheinend schon für mich so laufe
ich überhaupt richtig da haben sie
laufen mann ich habe keine reaktion zu
drehen ich glaube einfach immer weiter
niemandem über die komplette minecraft
weltkugel darüber wieder zu hause
das ist ein guter plan glaube auch nur
nur als ich bin auch dafür wenn ihm noch
neues thema oder naja kann man dem
iphone flexibel wenn es bei facebook
barbara ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba
ba war wo kann man besser erwärmen im
ofen oder mikrowelle
was kann man besser wenn also christian
berger fragt wo kann man katzen besser
wir im ofen oder mikrowelle
ich würde sagen mikrowelle ich bin auch
nicht ganz sicher also es muss man
ausprobieren praxis wenn man ja welten
zwischen theorie und praxis
da manchmal
ich weiß nicht wie winter sollte man
doch den wasserkocher nehmen natürlich
auch nach alternativen alles abgeklärt
können wir wieder neues thema angenommen
als dafür in frage man das meinen wir
nicht was dann
na ja seht ihr was
was haltet ihr vom vbc und unbekannten
deutschrap bzw deutschland allgemein und
was hört ihr in die richtung gerne für
künstler von wem die scheibe ist von
marktmacht sharing da macht das verfolge
das seit drei jahren und findet die idee
an sich dahinter eigentlich sehr sehr
gut jungen rappern die chance geben sich
da was passiert wenn man das blaue
abbaut
was ist in der einschätzung das ist eine
festung
das ist was mit drei gold und bronze bei
uns 100 jemanden dabei
ich möchte keine orange power ist genug
mein alter ich finde nichts ja ich auch
nur hier
wir verzichten mario hejl auf warum
expeditionen findet bestimmt voll geile
sachen nicht nein nein nein nein nein
das schön das ist schön dort
da geht es um so ein tunnel durch den
berg fällt mir sehr
das letzte höhlen dich rein
es ist in meiner bude er ich glaube es
nicht
wieder ein dschungel und wieder läuft
jetzt in die richtige richtung
ich konnte nicht mal 1000 volt z nur
geradeaus in diese richtung ab jetzt
immer geradeaus schon immer schöne immer
toll was war das thema dvb t und hab ich
geredet und du warst nicht mal wieder
unterbrochen
was ist denn dein lieblingskünstler also
ich verfolge das vorbild die seit drei
jahren
und ich finde das eigentlich ganz schön
dass dort kleinen rappern die chance
gegeben wird natürlich sich dort unter
beweis zu stellen
da so was nicht oft möglich ist dann
musik oft bei youtube einfach runter
geht und dies die einzige möglichkeit
ist das bei youtube oder das laptop oder
keine bietet er doch meist genommen
im video zur auswahl wird ihr heißt vbt
ich weiß nicht was uns geht video battle
turnier geht schlecht wechsel besser und
klopft ich hab gerade auch was ganz
anderes gefallen trainer gehören dazu
ich wollte dass kleinen rappern die
chance geben wird dass ich unter beweis
zu stellen da sie oft mit ihren eigenen
videos und songs die dann bei sound oder
bei youtube hochgeladen werden nicht so
die aufmerksamkeit bekommen und das beim
vbc möglich ist dass die dort halt eine
runde weiter kommen dadurch wird ihnen
kaum gegeben likes auf ihre
facebook-seite et cetera was sich da
dann halt alles so resultiert wenn die
da mitmachen und die kleine ahnung also
ich finde es eigentlich aus den rappern
bisher das ist auch so ein kleiner
unterschied zu bestimmten anderen
castingshows wie dsds wo die alle so
gegen ein antreten dass aus den
künstlern dass man die immer noch kennen
zum beispiel weekend den kannte damals
keiner da in seiner ersten runde dagegen
dagegen war dass es an zwei minuten
metal oder so das hat damit angefangen
bei relativ kurz aber ist dann halt
relativ schnell weiter gekommen hat im
nachhinein auf das finale dagegen basten
gewonnen und weekend and man jetzt halt
immer noch so und dsds-gewinner kann er
aber auch allgemein so so was er da noch
vergeblich künstler also vorbild gute
idee und meine lieblings quartal ist das
eine fette schlucht und diamanten alter
die weckte ihr sogar ein baum in der
schlucht seine lieblingskünstler ich
finde die bewertung der total scheiße
dieses jahr nicht dabei ist nicht dabei
erwischen
wer drin ist ist schon bekannt gegeben
weil ja seit drei tagen erfolgt nicht so
sehr wie immer komplette reime bude
truppe ist drin also fortune beckmann
dollar john et cetera war auch klar die
an die große fanbase von allen die
mitmachen wer es noch so alles drin also
die üblichen fall ist eine jury allein
entschieden oder da durften die designer
mit abstimmen ich glaube aber nur weiß
nicht ob ihm nur user voting auf jeden
fall ich bei rappers in abgestimmt für
films eclipse und beckmann und die sind
auch alle weiter auszugrenzen
letztes jahr hat glaube ich gewonnen
also dass das jetzt ein unterschied
zwischen vw und suzuki splash und ich
weiß nicht was von beiden man besser
sagen kann bei vw hat man ja ein
preisgeld dass man durch gewinne bei
vorbild splash all diesen splash
auftritt ich weiß nicht was man da
besser sein kann was etwas besser sei
weil die einen mögen natürlich über das
die da ein bisschen fame abgreifen
können auf dem display wenn dann die
ganzen zuschauer sind und die anderen
die sagen dann wach so 5000 euro sondern
auch ganz geil
5000 euro hat man ja oder mehr glaube
ich sogar noch weil sind aber nicht
genau so um den dreh ja keine ahnung das
thema ist wichtigstes vor allem halten
könnte als gerade die notorisch erreicht
er warte mal was man aber die
koordinaten nach hause ich bin gerade
eben wieder zu hause um ihr verbeeks 100
für dich und z 200 200 bis zu dem bett -
2400 also nochmal bitte die koordinaten
x100 z 200 scheiße
die folge ist übrigens schon längst
wieder vorbei dann sagen wir den dass
meinungs- und profitieren von nächstes
mal tschüss und